au brésil 500 roses rouges sur la plage
de copacabana de rio de janeiro pour les
cinq cent mille morts liées au virus la
barre a été franchi hier une action
symbolique pour critiquer également la
gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement de trahir ball sonar ou
accusées de minimiser la pandémie
écoutez mondiaux rendus ou avons-nous
fait fausse route
associer bad la société doit répondre à
cette question car malheureusement une
partie de la réponse se trouve chez les
politiques qui n'ont jamais fait preuve
d'empathie pour le peuple brésilien
pendant cette pandémie ne mange plus
luxueux et beaucoup de brésiliens qui on
vient de le voir contestent cette
politique de rigueur bol sonar aux
voyelles et les précisions de augusto à
augusta lunar 10 depuis sao paulo au
brésil le brésil deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé par la colline 19 derrière les
etats unis a franchi samedi dernier le
seuil des 500 milles nord le week end a
également été marqué par de nombreuses
manifestations contre la gestion de lier
vos le sonar ou dans plusieurs grandes
villes du pays
les milliers de manifestants demandaient
la destitution du président brésilien
mais surtout l'accélération de la
vaccination il énoncé par ailleurs le
fait que le gouvernement est ignorée en
août dernier la proposition de vente de
70 millions de doses du vaccin fader
alors que le brésil compte plus de 2000
décès liés l'aco vie de chaque jour le
chef d'état continue de minimiser la
dangerosité du virus l'a récemment
organisé deux manifestations à moto à
rio et à sang froid au dos il l'a aussi
ouvertement inciter les citoyens à
cesser de porter le masque et en raison
de la lenteur de la vaccination durée
lâchement précoce des restrictions
sanitaires et de la circulation effréné
des variants la troisième vague risque
d'atteindre le brésil de plein fouet au
moment de la copa america on tourne
de foot que molson araud a décidé
d'accueillir à bras ouverts après les
désistements de l'argentine et de la
colombie pour des raisons sanitaires